in Chapter two is one of this year's
most anticipated films and a lot of
people are excited for the return of the
movies creepy child murdering clown
Pennywise well ladies and gentlemen
there is one group of people who are
definitely not excited real clowns okay
yes
they say the it movie promotes negative
views of clowns so with us tonight yeah
there's always someone with us tonight
is someone who wants to speak on behalf
of the outraged clown community please
welcome butterscotch the clown let's get
him out here yeah hello there
butterscotch
so I guess clowns are pretty unhappy
about how the new it movie portrays
clowns you bet we are
Pennywise makes clowns look like crispy
monsters when most of us clowns are
actually sweet and cuddly like me yeah
I understand your frustration
butterscotch so did you come to
comic-con to protest this this movie oh
no I'm here all week at comic-con to
spread the message that clowns are nice
in fact I've been driving this van
around all week okay in San Diego wait
oh my god it says who wants to eat
babies oops some letters must have
fallen off it says who wants 12 seats
for babies wait a minute giving away
baby seats well giving away slightly
used baby seats that mysteriously ended
up in my possession is a great way to
connect with families and let them know
I won't murder their kids I mean I won't
murder their kids I won't murder
who likes birthday parties I don't know
what this has to do with the movie it
but sure butterscotch I guess we all
like birthday parties who denies I got
the birthday clown for you me you see I
believe every child's last birthday
deserves to be special
which is why I let the birthday boy or
girl spin my wheel of fun tivities bring
in the fun wheel the fun wheel in here
ladies and gentlemen here you look at
all the fun we can have together you
wait a minute hold on it says Russian
roulette
her ass the e oh yeah that is very
strange
10 minutes slow dance well that's a fun
one no no and what's this right here
it's just a bunch of simp oh yeah it's
that summons Prince Hager off it you
drop screams let's hope it doesn't land
on that one no spin the fun wheels right
well give it a shot right here I'll give
it a little spin okay I'm confused
it says animal balloon yes don't you
mean balloon animals oh you'll wish I
did I make all sorts of animal balloons
by finding flat little fellas near the
highway
I found this possum near the i-5 on
that's a possum it used to be oh and
here's a snake I made into a dog balloon
ruff ruff
this is okay you know what I think I
think you've wasted enough of our time
agree to disagree
before I leave I just want to say please
don't come to comic-con and Pennywise
cosplay when there are so many other fun
cosplay ideas that don't glamorize child
murdering cloud9
here's a great one look familiar Conan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
play at comic-con yeah and I got all the
details right she's even anatomically
correct I'm not thirsty and no one wants
to see that okay here's another great
cosplay idea for Friends of science
fiction recognize this classic character
Conan I'm not sure it's I guess it's
just some kind of astronaut huh well
maybe this will jog your memory
peekaboo you see it's the crotch burst
different aliens now who wants to see me
making spit acid
[Applause]
no stomach when I told that boy to watch
the clown everybody we have a
[Applause]